we are increasingly seeing reporting
that the reason for all of this trouble
at mar-a-lago
is a traitor
or a mole
inside donald trump's circle now there's
a couple different
elements to this one is is there a high
level traitor like mark meadows mark
meadows name is one that is frequently
mentioned
but then there's also a more nitty
gritty question of like is there just
someone at mar-a-lago that has been
involved in feeding information to the
feds about where things are being kept
in donald trump's home or whatever the
case may be increasingly seeing more and
more reporting on this business insider
quoting axios trump allies think there's
a traitor in mar-a-lago who informed on
him to the fbi
allies of trump believe an aid or aids
to trump
may have flipped and provided evidence
to the fbi about what he was keeping in
his mar-a-lago resort in florida per
axios
when we look at the axios report
one big thing trump world suspects a
flipper
trump world is abuzz with speculation
about which close aids or aid has
flipped and provided additional
sensitive information to the fbi about
what trump was keeping there
trump's orbit is always an environment
rife with mistrust and paranoia and it
is intensified in a detail that seems
too novelistic to be true a focal point
of the search was the mar-a-lago
basement christina bob a lawyer for
trump told the washington post as
lawyers held discussions with the
justice department this spring bob said
trump's legal team searched through two
dozen two to three dozen boxes in a
basement storage area hunting for
documents that could be considered
presidential records
bob told the post that in june trump
lawyers showed those boxes to
investigators and they already looked
through it she said the investigators
didn't think the storage unit was
secured so trump officials added a lock
fbi agents broke through the lock during
the search and then took a dozen boxes
newsweek also exclusively reporting an
informer told the fbi what documents
trump was hiding and where the raid on
mar-a-lago was based largely on
information from an fbi confidential
human source who was able to identify
what classified documents trump was
still hiding in the locations
the officials who have direct knowledge
of the fbi's deliberations were granted
anonymity
said the raid of trump's home was
deliberately timed to occur when trump
was
away fbi decision makers in washington
and miami thought that denying trump a
photo op or a platform from which to
grandstand or try to thwart the raid
would lower its profile that failed it
prompted a furious response from
republican leaders
this is completely plausible
as with many of these things
we often because of the documentation
being not public
we often don't understand and because of
the need to protect informants we often
never learn everybody that is in touch
with law enforcement in advance of such
an action but it would be completely
reasonable to think that something like
this took place marjorie taylor green
believes it and she's on the case and
she wants the traitors found they do not
want him in there
and they're so hell bent on it guess
what we now know that there was an fbi
informant
at mar-a-lago
an fbi informant working at mar-a-lago
by the way she says she knows this based
on media reports the very same media she
often decries as fake news that tells
lies again
it's just
what's convenient for us right now right
now it's convenient to believe those
reports in the media who is that and how
many other fbi informants are around
president trump on a daily basis working
at his clubs working at mar-a-lago or
maybe bed minister or on
bed minister i i know that's completely
an aside
bedminster
bed minister please marjorie staff these
are the things i want to know because
they're traitors they are traitors and
they're helping the deep state and
they're helping the people these are the
enemies within these are the real
enemies and they are there to purposely
purposely create something against
president trump that is not there
it's absolutely not there and everyone
knows it everyone knows it and if these
people
so traitor is the word that marjorie
taylor green and quite frankly many in
mega world are using will we ever learn
who it was probably not but from a
political standpoint at a bigger picture
level
mark meadows has never
publicly accused cassidy hutchinson of
lying during her testimony to the
january 6th committee
and so
merely speculatively
it seems to me quite plausible
that meadows is somewhere involved in
providing information to someone not
could be fbi could be january 6 maybe i
don't know
but his silence when many others have
said cassidy is lying
is very notable uh that's probably
separate from whatever so-called traitor
was at mar-a-lago probably two different
stories